and then we called it an ipad talk and
now we have to go back to calling it a
board talk so take it away thanks
sorry have to
make everyone change notation uh so
thanks for the invitation to speak
please tell me if i'm standing in front
of things or if i'm writing too small so
everything i talk about will be joint
work with john niles weed who i think
i may have forgotten to mention in my
abstract uh so sorry about that
uh so i'll talk about this class of
problems that we studied
which is a variant of
certain
problems over over graphs as i'll
describe but i'll start with some
more practical motivation
so we're interested in
problems coming from tracking
say many
moving particles
so imagine here we have
you know
space
we have particles
particles move somehow
we're interested in i don't know
here
etc
and
we would like to keep track of this as
as it happens so how do we actually you
know kind of observe this this kind of
process in practice well
we can think here's time
we start at some point and periodically
we just observe the positions of these
things so we can't observe these
continuous trajectories we just take
these kind of snapshots so
here
here and at each time i won't try to
actually reproduce them but we see some
points here they've moved a bunch
here they've moved some more
and so on
and i guess it doesn't look like they've
moved very much
uh so from this somehow there are some
true trajectories here you know in
between they moved somehow this one
maybe went down here and then back up
and this one did something like this
and
what we would like to track is their
identities
between these snapshots so
this kind of pairing here
so this
is the matching that's why that's in the
name of this kind of problem
uh that we would like
to
infer
um okay
so
from from this kind of motivation this
kind of problem of learning these
matchings just from frame to frame
arises
and we want to answer all the usual
questions so in particular
i'll i'll try to present in a way that
stays kind of fairly close to this
motivation as as we'll see
but so the first question is so let's
say this is you know we take some time
step
of length uh
delta
and the first question is what is the
cost
in the error in these matchings so i'll
be more precise in a moment
uh
with
a
longer
delta so if we wait longer between
snapshots how does that cause us to make
more and more errors as we try to
estimate this
and then okay the the real you know
thing
everyone is is waiting for is uh
algorithms that do this well
or poorly
and statistical or computational
limitations
on solving
okay so
i'll describe kind of a model that we
propose for
just this this one
sub problem here between two frames
um and i think it's actually maybe a
little bit clearer to
describe
what we look at
and then explain how prior work
is kind of a natural
simplification of this so our model and
this is a model of one step of this
process
so
we start with uh
so at the earlier time we start with a
bunch of points
from x1 up to
xn and for the sake of simplicity
we'll think of these as being just
standard gaussians
uh so that's that's the the kind of toy
model of where these points come from
then
we make some
displacements of these
with some variance so the sigma squared
is an important parameter so these are
initial
these are displacements
in this
in this particle tracking application
should i think of v is three like
video or they're like there are more
abstract things to have in mind where d
is high because i took a lot of
measurements or something in the picture
i drew here in this example we should
think d is two
and time is passing um and then i'll
talk about uh all kinds of scalings of
dimension as as time permits but that's
one of the interesting things is that
the the behavior of this kind of changes
at certain ways that uh so in particular
with with d depending on n so d being a
constant is kind of maybe the natural
applied situation
and we'll talk a bunch about that but as
you let d get bigger with n some new
phenomena come up and get there too
other questions
just an interrupt as
as desired
so then the
the later points
initial final
are just what i get when i take these
and i push them along like like so
uh so again
here are the x i's
and we apply these perturbations to them
and we form these yjs we don't know
which one comes from which the true
thing that happened is you know
something like this and we're trying to
learn this this matching so how do we
represent that well we can say
there's some
hidden permutation
which i think of as drawn
a uniformly random permutation
and
what i observe
is
the x's
and then the y's permuted
and i want
to
recover
this pi star
so this is this is the full kind of
setup of this toy model of this kind of
task
and
we'll look at a particular way of
estimating 5 star which is the maximum
likelihood
estimator
so here you know you write out your
gaussian densities and what not and you
get
that
a reasonable way to estimate this is to
try to minimize
over permutations
this kind of sum so we just
try to minimize the sum of square
distances in all ways to match these
together this is the same
you can drop all of these
norm terms
because each one happens exactly once
and
so this is this is the sort of specific
kind of estimator we'll we'll look at
and this uh can be solved efficiently so
unlike some other
uh situations where there are questions
about well can we can we even
efficiently commute this here we
definitely can
and compute
as a linear assignment problem
this is a
an optimization problem on a matrix
which contains either of these two
pieces of uh
so this is just i mean you can think of
this as a linear program and there are
more
practical efficient algorithms uh
finding the largest permutation uh in in
this matrix
and so the question is
how well does does this estimator work
so in particular
count the number of errors it makes
define this set e
of everything that
matches incorrectly
and we'll consider
the number of these errors that it makes
random variable as n goes to infinity
okay so this is the only estimator i'll
look at i'll maybe mention some
kind of
problems about whether other algorithms
might do and do better than this but
this is this is the main thing to talk
about
um okay so now
i'll try to write here and and tell me
if when you stop being able to see
hopefully it'll all fit so let me
mention the prior work here
it differs from what we're doing on kind
of two major uh
counts first of all
people have looked at the same kind of
thing with this matrix having
independent entries
and second uh focusing on
the threshold of so-called strong
recovery
which is when
the number of errors you make is
little o of n versus
of order n
um and as we'll see and in talking about
that we'll return to the
original motivation um it might make
some sense to think about the kind of
finer grained behavior of this number of
errors to learn something about actually
solving that kind of problem over and
over again
uh but here kind of the main example
uh or maybe the one that we can analyze
most thoroughly has been for instance so
here we should think of w as having the
squared distances
uh and this
having one of two exponential
distributions
so
this one is small lambda here is a
constant so this is
in the
case of the planted entries
and otherwise this distance is large and
this kind of follows
some work on the unplanted version of
this
by parisi and then aldis and others
strong older line of work and here you
can establish
a sharp threshold for strong recovery
this happens to be at lambda equals
four so
the line of work where this was done
this this kind of thing was introduced
uh for a different set of distributions
um in this paper by let's see
i believe this is chertkov
croak
uh
you don't recall who vias and then
shakkala and zdevarova
2010. then kind of picking up the thread
there is a paper by chris moore
maharami and shu
just a few years ago which did actually
treat
this model and establish this threshold
and then
kind of elaborating on this and also
treating other distributions
there's another recent paper of uh ding
woo
and yang just this year
so
all of these uh results are working
under this type of model saying where is
this sharp threshold if any how does the
uh kind of
in this regime here how does the
curve of how this amount of error
depends on a parameter like the slam to
look and et cetera et cetera
so
uh
maybe we'll have time to see at the very
end how a certain kind of extreme
version of this problem where d gets
very large with
actually recovers this kind of limit
but uh for the most part the kind of
moral of the story will be that these
geometric problems behave quite
differently and have some different
phenomena
so any questions
from this setup
if not i can start
stating some results finally let me note
before that
maybe you can see here and if not it's
not a big deal so for us
an extra complication is that here
there's only one
kind of parameter
involved in
in this whole problem which is lambda
for us
we have two parameters
which are sigma squared which depends on
n
and d which
possibly
also depends on it like i mentioned
before
um so
this is just to say that the even just
the description of the results will be a
little bit more complicated than just
saying there's a sharp threshold at some
particular one value so i'll have to
describe how both of those look
uh
let me leave this up
so the first
set of results um concerns maybe the
regime that's closest to this kind of
problem
so
at least make sure that i get through
these
and this is when
d which can depend on n is much smaller
than log event
and here
there will be
a few
natural regimes so here i'm
imagining the rate of growth of d is
fixed and i'll say
properties about sigma that create
different amounts of error so
these three thresholds will be sigma
much smaller than n to the
minus four over d
so the last one will be sigma at least
n to the minus two over d and the middle
one will be
in between
alpha over d
and alpha is some number
between minus four and minus two
and let me draw just a picture of what
the results say
so here i'll put so let's again let's
imagine we'll work with this parameter
alpha here i'll put that
and on the y-axis i'll write
on a logarithmic scale in n
the number
of errors that i make so here you can
imagine this may be plus one so that
when the error is zero then this is zero
so
here will be this threshold lambda is
minus four
minus minus
so when the amount of noise
is uh
very small
then
we can achieve
perfect recovery so here this is only on
this logarithmic scale but the number of
errors is really is really zero with a
high probability in here
up here let's say somewhere is one
when there is a lot of noise one sigma
squared is bigger than the second
threshold
then
we make
a macroscopic number of errors so this
is that
same omega then
amount of error from before and in
between here
this grows
uh linearly with
with alpha
so these are the the kind of main
results in this regime and you can be a
little bit more precise about well how
far from actually linear uh
linear error in n is this here and and
so on but this is the general idea
so this is
a
this is b
and let's see
so the middle line doesn't depend on
alpha
the middle line here
yeah so this this is um this this whole
thing here is i believe two
uh plus
alpha over two
this is the exponent of the error
so how do we
argue
uh this kind of thing and and see that
this is in fact what happens
the analysis is similar to the kind of
thing that those papers
over there do and in particular the ones
the one of
the
mmx paper
so
we count
[Music]
the number of a certain structure in
here called augmenting cycles
so
this is maybe a slightly different
definition than usual
say that a cycle like this so these are
indices between one and n different
indices is augmenting if
and that's adding it
pushing the labels along this
cycle
makes the objective function
better
so it augments the thing we're trying to
optimize
and it's pretty easy to check
that
the set of errors that you make
is some
maximal
disjoint union of these things
the incorrectly labeled uh
the incorrectly labeled indices
decompose into these and this
decomposition must be maximal you can
kind of put another one in there where
it would be favorable to make that
that to kind of adjust along that cycle
and
this this permutation would not be the
optimal one
so because of this
we can use
first and second moment methods
to bound
the number of errors above and below
the mmx paper didn't do the second
moment that was right right yes so the
kind of positive results of mmx use the
first moment
uh
meaning the ones that show that this is
small the negative results use some
fancy thing following parisian all this
and then the second paper down there uh
red use the second one thanks
um okay so
so anyway so i won't get into the
details of this but we can get an idea
for why this kind of thing happens by
looking at how the counts of augmenting
cycles look so let's say
ck
is the number
of augmenting k cycles
and
let me draw
pictures of how
the typical value of ck looks in these
three machines
and this will also give me a chance to
gesture at some of the
proof ideas
so
i'll plot
log again on this kind of log scale the
log expectation of c k
over log of n
here will be zero
and here will be k
and the cycles start with two three
four
five etcetera so
in regime a
what happens is that so the idea is that
always uh the two cycles will make kind
of the dominant contribution and that's
what lets us carry out
this whole analysis because they're sort
of small and possible to count fairly
easily so there's some kind of
curve
that gives these quantities and actually
computing this and analyzing it is kind
of the main the main technical device
but here the
number of the expected number of two
cycles is polynomially smaller than n so
you know high probability there are none
of them and then you know this this
decreases from there and so union union
bounding over all of those gives you
this perfect recovery result
now the same thing
in regime b
so here somewhere up here
is one
again
in this
intermediate error regime
the two cycles make kind of a dominant
contribution
but it's somewhere between 0 and 1 now
and again the rest
we shall make in even an even smaller
amount
so
again to count the number of errors and
okay you have to say something about how
you know typically these two cycles are
all kind of disjoint and then sprinkled
you know uniformly
among all possible pairs but you can do
that and you'll you'll see that this is
this is the true amount of error that
you make in this situation so here we
really do here we just do first moment
and here we do first plus second moment
and then
in
will people see if i kind of
over here okay
um
so okay let me let me draw
see so here one of two uh things
happens
uh here the number of two cycles
is
at or above one
and in fact it can either
go
down like this or it can even and this
happens
sometimes go down and then go back up
and so really there will be quite a lot
of augmenting larger cycles but still
the two cycles make a dominant
contribution
so
let me say to conclude
uh
two small things about how this changes
um
or about why this is useful for this
question and how this changes uh for a
higher dimension so first about about
this question like why why do we care
about
actually computing this exact exponent
so
[Music]
we talked in the paper about an example
of an
brownian motions
so here i'm really going to
go with kind of the motivation over
there
and here so in one kind of time step
how much does some x i move to y i well
it follows some you know brownian path
here and this displacement
has a variance
delta
so
the amount
you can check from over there
the number of errors you expect to make
per step
is like a delta to the d over 2
times n
so this is using using this
and then
so how many time steps
maybe this is this is all i'll say i'll
finish
time steps to
kind of decohere so if you're trying to
track all of these things
to lose track of all of them or of
almost all of them how long does that
take well that takes n divided by
this
time steps how much time does it take
did you go here
that's the number of
steps
times the amount of time that passes in
each step
and so this
is like delta to the one minus d over
two over n
so let me just admire this formula for a
second and i'll wrap up so
uh for this is assuming that the errors
that you make in each time step are kind
of disjoint or affecting different
indices uh in d equals one you can
convince yourself that that actually
doesn't happen at all brownian motions
intersect and kind of bounce around each
other a lot but what this leads us to
predict
is that for d equals 2
maybe surprisingly
we actually expect there to be very
little returns to sampling more and more
frequently in terms of how long you can
track for kind of cumulatively so it's a
little
return
on
delta whereas for d at least three
suddenly this becomes
a polynomial
return on delta
so and we do some numerical experiments
also and verify that more or less it
looks like this is what happens so this
is the main open problem actually not
these larger dimension things this is
kind of a more practical thing
that uh
i'd like to advertise there seems to be
this interesting transition between
dimension two and dimension three in
terms of tracking and here i think there
are lots of interesting open problems in
particular is this iterative computation
of the maximum likelihood estimator
where in fact you can check that you can
replace it with a greedy algorithm
and it'll do just the same is that
optimal
or is it optimal if you don't get to
store
you know a huge number of snapchats and
you have to do this in an online fashion
can you improve in particular
on this kind of poor performance
um
in the class of online algorithms
okay so thanks for your attention when d
scale says log n there's also a
surprising jump here it's it's strange
take a look at the paper if you're
curious but
thank you
[Applause]
so maybe one question pretend as we
switch over to the zoomtalk setup
yeah extremely optimistically about
three regimes d less than log n d equal
to log n which is kind of an inter or d
you know proportional to log n where
this
jump happens and then once d grows
faster than log n then it behaves like
the independent regime in particular
with this inner product choice of the w
matrix i wrote before it starts to look
like gaussians either centered or with
the mean shifted and the thing you get
for the mle recovers so the dw
x y paper uh mentions this for gaussians
and you get you got the same result as
they do
but the mle is sub-optimal you should
actually use a greedy algorithm but
a particular kind of greedy algorithm
and it gets a little bit hairy
cool
thanks tim
um
next up we have jayadev uh
from the boot camp our experience was
that for jaydev to hear us